welcome to water's world i'm jesse
waters the democrats lost cause that's
the subject of tonight's waters words
democrats have had their eyes on texas
for decades
it's gotten so close to turning blue
they can taste it
ronald reagan won texas by 30 points and
almost
40 years later trump won just by single
digits
so right when it's within striking
distance
trump beat biden there by just six
points under these
loose pandemic rules democrats want to
make those rules
permanent texas republicans say no
we're going to make it easier to vote
but harder to cheat
texas democrats start howling racism and
fly to d.c
leaving the legislature half empty texas
democrats won't vote because they can't
cheat next time
that's what this is all about i read the
bill
so you don't have to and my buddy harold
ford jr
democrat couldn't point out a single
thing in it
that restricted voting senate bill 7
so-called racist restrictions on voting
are as follows
you can't have a polling station in a
tent or a parking garage
so no pop-up polling stations and when
you request a ballot by mail
you have to write your signature and you
have to write your id that's on your
license or if you don't have a driver's
license the last four numbers of your
social security number
da done how's that restrictive
it's not they actually expand voting
hours all across the board and
companies are required to allow workers
to go leave work on election day and go
vote
here's actually what makes it harder to
cheat in texas and why the democrats
are howling you can't kick poll watchers
out of polling stations
and the polling workers have to be able
to see the counts
and if you're in a big city they have to
live stream the counting rooms also
counties have to clean up these old
dusty voter rules
and all votes have to have a paper trail
so they can't just disappear in a
machine
and paying for votes becomes a felony
democrats don't like that
and the machines have to have software
that aren't allowed to change votes and
officials can't just
mail out ballots without having them
requested so no mass mailing of ballots
and
no ballot harvesting tell me what the
objection is
to all of these things in the bill
what's the objection well
because they seem to be looking for a
problem all of the things i just read
that's actually in the bill what is
objectionable
couldn't answer now that trump's gone
and the pandemic's over
democrat talking points are empty they
have nothing
they actually have to debate the policy
and they can't so they're just just
lying and screaming racism biden
couldn't name a single thing in the
texas bill that actually disenfranchises
anybody 21st century
jim crow assault is real it's
unrelenting
and we're going to challenge it
vigorously are you on the side of truth
or lies
fact or fiction justice or injustice
democracy or
autocracy that's what it's coming down
to
stand up for god's sake and help prevent
this concerted effort to undermine our
elections
and the sacred right to vote have you no
shame
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war they don't even
believe their own lies
if this was really jim crow why are
texas democrats smiling like goofballs
with a case of light beer
if black americans were really being
disenfranchised
they'd have their game faces on and jim
crow by the way was a democrat operation
to stop blacks from voting
it was republicans who freed the slaves
kamala harris not a student of history
even compared the texas fleabaggers to
frederick douglass
they took bold courageous action
in line with the legacy of everyone from
frederick douglass was over my right
shoulder
when he fought for the right of black
men to vote in america
to the legacy that includes all those
women who marched down pennsylvania
avenue
for women's right to vote to all of
those folks who shed their blood on the
edmund pettus bridge
to make sure that we would in 1965 pass
the voting rights act
earth to kamala frederick douglass
slapped on a disguise borrowed cash took
a train and a steamboat out of slave
state maryland
into philly risking his life the
democrats haven't risked their biscuits
they hopped on a private jet and posted
selfies
frederick douglass was a great orator
and from what i've heard so far
none of these democrats can explain how
this republican bill
restricts voting because it doesn't
black people don't have social security
numbers
black americans don't have id here's ami
horowitz asking white and black voters
their opinions on voting laws
that these democrats have been furious
with for years
do you have an opinion on voter id laws
uh yeah they're usually pretty racist
i think voter id laws are a way to
perpetuate racism do you think it
suppresses the
african-american vote definitely because
they're less likely to have
state ids these type of people don't
live in
areas with easy access to dmvs do you
think that's harder for black people to
go online
well i feel like they don't have the
knowledge of how of like how it works
do you have id normally do you care
ideas yes i have state id yes i do
do you know anybody who any black person
doesn't carry id no
everyone that i know has an id why would
they say that you know how to get the av
sport
i also heard a lot that black people
especially poor black people have no
access to the internet
that's just stupidity honestly everybody
has access to the internet
what does that save you for the people
who have this perception of like they're
pretty much ignorant though
i think it is a little racist there you
have it
the only people who think these laws are
racist or suppress
the black vote are white liberals they
want to scare americans into submission
with these racist lies but
it's a lost cause because we have the
truth on our side